somebody that I think you might know uh
there's a famous actor Tom Hardy but
he's also doing uh quite a bit of Jiu
Jitsu the reason this makes sense to
bring up now is he's also I saw
narrating a new Sky original series
called Predators coming out in December
where they follow five different
predators and tell their full story
about all the fighting The Killing and
all that kind of stuff and he's doing
that he's like it's like Morgan's uh
it's like Morgan Freeman from March of
the Penguins it's Tom Hardy for for the
Predators uh so I don't I saw a bear and
a lion in the it's in the trailer but
they also had something I didn't watch
it too careful but they had something
like a hyena so they think they were
talking about I don't know if it's a
hyena but something like that like pack
animals yeah that attack in Chinese have
formidable formidable animals so it's
not all about size it's about like
strategy you know the most important
thing in nature is numbers like uh you
know a pack of animals will always
destroy a single animal and I think that
show in particular is not 100 about who
wins or so on it's about the fascinating
stories of how these Predators sort of
dominate that particular environment
because it's it's not about these like
artificial matchups it's about giving
your environment how do you succeed and
all that kind of stuff maybe we could do
golden Ryan versus a house cat
the Gordon might have a a small chance
against the house cat maybe maybe
see now I know you're just trolling me I
I think Gordon has a chance against uh
well definitely against
the smaller Apes
but I have no way of proving it and and
the internet will say I'm an idiot so
there you go the internet is correct
every so often so there's a oh it's
funny enough I'm looking at uh Tom's
Instagram he has a picture with Hanzo
he's competed recently which is very
cool in Jiu Jitsu that's awesome that's
tough to do for a celebrity to step up
oh yeah absolutely yeah
um he he used to um consult with me a
little bit on um uh moose when he was
starting out he's a very very nice
person oh about Jiu Jitsu yeah yeah you
ask questions about Judas he struck me
as being a very very nice person I would
love to be a fly in that wall but he uh
he made a post on Instagram which I'd
love to get your opinion on it has very
much like a John Donahoe style of
digging into the philosophy of the
impact of Jiu Jitsu on one's life
is this Instagram post 18 pages long yes
he's got potential then yes with a
profound deep picture of somebody
practicing the artificial I think I
think uh I think he's at least a trainee
in this art of the Donna her style of
communication
if Miyamoto Musashi would be alive today
he'll probably be doing these five page
Instagram posts like you do uh addiction
writes Tom Hardy addiction is difficult
and complex stuff to navigate as is
mental health subjects which are both
deeply personal for me and extremely
close to my heart it is an honor to be
able to represent the charity and my
team reorg and the great work they do
supporting the mental health and
well-being of veterans of service
military and First Responders through
the therapeutic benefits of Jiu Jitsu
and Fitness training he represented them
in this competition that he competed in
simple training for me as a hobby and a
private love has been fundamentally key
to further develop a deeper sense of
inner resilience calm and well-being I
can't stress the importance it has had
and the impact of my life and my fellow
teammates and he goes on to talk about
this organization reorg that uses
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu to form a therapy to
overcome physical and mental challenges
strengthen social connections and
improve overall health and well-being
this is for Veterans for people going
through PTSD
they have saved lives around the world
by not only providing an effective and
positive means for navigating and
managing the challenging psychological
aspects of military and first respondent
careers but also has allowed many to
find a renewed sense of purpose identity
and Community that's often lost when
transitioning to civilian life do you
have thoughts about that sort of the
effects of Jiu Jitsu on
on on folks who've gone through some
really difficult yeah things in their
life
first off that I think this is the a
beautiful statement by by Mr hardy that
uh I must
give him a phone call after this and
talk to him it was beautiful to read
um
one thing that's always struck me when
um I train people who either have a
military background or on more than a
few occasions
um we have special forces soldiers come
in and train with us for a week or two
and
when you talk to them
the overwhelming sentiment I get when
the conversation's over and we go our
separate ways is I'm always asking
myself
the transition from military life
especially the more extreme military
lives of Special Force Special Forces
soldiers
back to civilian life it must be the
craziest experience of all
you've got people who
of fighting and dying alongside their
their comrades
in the most extreme circumstances that
any human being can go through
and then they're pulled back into a life
where
people are arguing with them over
parking spots just like the average
person's
day-to-day life is so mundane
that imagine what must be going through
a man's head
who a few weeks or months ago was
literally fighting for his life and his
comrades lives watching people that he
loved die or get mutilated in front of
him
things that
you know in a matter of seconds people's
lives can be torn apart and changed
forever and then suddenly you get thrown
into a life where people are arguing
over
you know who's who's cut who off who in
line to buy a coffee the intensity of
camaraderie and love the Earth for each
other and then you go from incredible
intensity and War to
just mundane boring life and going from
one to the other where people are
yelling at you or nagging you over
issues that just seem so inconsequential
compared to what you've been through
and you're supposed to take these people
seriously and listen to them but neither
do that you do have trauma visions of
dead brothers and sisters and you feel
like you can't really talk to these
civilians about it there's nothing in
their experience that would enable you
to have a conversation with them like
they they don't even how do you talk to
your new girlfriend about you know
watching one of your friends legs get
taken off like there's no conversation
you could have with them
um
so I find that typically
um
they do best when they hang out with
each other because they have shared
experience and they can talk about these
things
um
but I do find that
most Jiu Jitsu schools have something
like a kind of military barracks
demeanor to them of like camaraderie
hard work shared hard work
um teamwork
uh uh building towards a goal over time
the acquisition of skills usually along
with that a kind of
want of a better word or rustic and
primitive sense of humor and and
um a kind of soldierly way of talking to
each other and disparaging you know
self-deprecating sense of humor and it's
something that most people with military
service kind of
naturally come into because it's part of
what they were in and so it's like a
toned down version of it which enables
them to form a stepping stone between
the uh the military life that they were
in
all the way down to civilian life and
Jiu Jitsu is kind of like a bridge
between those two and also the honesty
so you said like the skill acquisition
the honesty of really testing that skill
there is a deep honesty to war in in
this in a distant way
but in a way there's an honesty to Jitsu
deals of technique working and not and
there's a final there is simulated death
it's not real death it's simulated death
on the mat yeah and there's a similar
kind of honesty there and there's also a
similar kind of esteem towards skill
just as regular soldiers look up to
Special Forces soldiers because they see
them as people have
you know greatest skill than themselves
something to Aspire to so too and and
Jiu-Jitsu like the thing that we esteem
most on the judicial matter skill no one
gets a damn what you look like or what
you think that you you judge mostly by
your skill level and
um uh and so they tend to identify with
that I do think that um uh most people
from a military background kind of find
a natural gravitation towards the the
atmosphere of Jiu-Jitsu learning and if
it proves to be a a positive way for
them to to rehabilitate and come back
into civilian lives and uh that's a
wonderful wonderful thing I know we're
linked with uh we defy which is a uh an
organization which caters to
former soldiers who were badly injured
in combat and many of whom lost limbs
and
or suffered mental trauma and they come
in and train and they often speak very
very highly of their degree to which
Jujitsu has helped them come back into
civilian life and and for them it's even
worse because they come back not only
mentally
but physically disadvantaged after war
and
um uh and I've always been proud to be
associated with we defy and I'm very
happy to see Tom working with this
organization is this an organization
based in England for English veterans or
is it International it's a good question
I'd have to look into it it certainly is
based uh uh in England but it could be
International
but it's just nice to see somebody use
that large platform yeah and also to
step on the
on the mat and show the kind of Jiu
Jitsu you would probably be proud of
chasing submissions you got you got an
arm lock you got a straight foot lock
we're not going to analyze the
techniques because you know there could
be uh doesn't matter different
perspectives it finishes the Finish yeah
no that's impressive
um he's actually quite an athlete he's
uh he's in great shape and um uh strong
and flexible and I'm glad he's doing
well with his Jujitsu and it's good to
see henzo's smiling face next to him I
can only imagine the conversations